persona 5 royal ads tons of new content
chief among them is the new 3rd semester
which features the ninth and final
palace but it's possible to miss all
that entirely if you don't meet certain
requirements it's an absolute must to
see all the game has to offer so here's
everything you need to do to unlock the
new content spoiler free as possible the
gist of this is that you need to rank up
three separate confidants to certain
ranks before specific dates some of the
ranks are gated by certain days and
events and if you don't rank them up by
then you'll miss out on the extra
gameplay and a new major story arts so
first let's start with garlic ecchi the
Justice Arcana oh I thought I heard
something about delicious pancakes in
the original persona 5 a caches
confidant Ark was tied to story events
and was unmissable but in p5 are you
choose to spend time with him you'll
first meet a catchy in early June when
you take the class field trip to the TV
station this is an unmissable story
event that kicks off rank one after rank
one he'll be in keachi gog to hang out
the new area in p5 r he'll be a catalyst
to show off some of the new things you
can do like play billiards and relax
with a jazz club you can achieve ranks 2
to 5 right after rank 1 and there's no
time gate on them however his confidant
rank 3 requires you to have knowledge
and charm stats at rank 3 before
engaging rank 6 is locked until a story
event on September 3rd and he'll be
waiting for you in Leblon rank 7 and 8
are then locked until November 2nd but
you must complete both before November
18 I won't explain why for spoilers sake
a word of advice though make sure you're
prepared to fight for rank 8 though you
can always retry if you don't succeed if
you do all those things correctly ranks
9 and 10 will unlock automatically as
the story progresses next let's move on
to Kazuma yoshizawa the new transfer
student at sujin Academy unfortunately I
forgot it
but it's fine I'll barely get wet if I
run to the station if anything it'll
make for good training
you'll bump into Kasumi on the train
early on but you won't truly interact
with her until the new park cleanup
event on May 30th
this is an unmissable story event and
you'll reach rank 1 with her and open up
her confidante route she holds the faith
Arkana you'll notice that Kasumi only
has five confidant ranks which is
different from everyone else
ranks two to five aren't gated by
anything and can be easily unlocked
after you officially meet her you'll
find her hanging out and keep you Joji -
you have until December 22nd to do all
of this so no pressure finally the last
important confidant to ensure you reach
the extra semester and Palace is Xu Jun
Academy's very own guidance counselor
Takuto Marquis who holds the counselor
on kana Mara key joins the story after
the first palace and is hired by the
school to help the students through
their problems there's an automatic
story event that introduces him and
since you and your friends have endured
traumatic experiences you're required to
go visit him early on from there
you'll reach rank 1 with him and
throughout the story you'll even see
moments of your fellow phantom thieves
receiving counselling from him as well
ranks 2 to 5 can be achieved immediately
after that ranks six to nine are then
gated until September 20th you can also
do ranks one through nine
after September 20th if you choose you
won't be locked out if you wait that
long however you will be locked out of
rank 10 if you do not reach rank 9 by
November 17 rank 10 then happens
automatically on November 18th if you
have reached rank 9 by then it's also
worth noting that Marquis raises your SP
cap and grants abilities like detox flow
and mindfulness which are extremely
useful he's also a great guy you
honestly should just meet with him
regardless now it's up to rank up
confidants faster make sure you're
carrying a persona with the same Arcana
as the person you're hanging out with
you'll receive more points for proper
dialogue options oh and lastly make sure
to refuse any deal that would compromise
your morals throughout the course of the
story so that's it if you accomplish all
these steps you should be ready for the
brand new palace 3rd semester and
everything that comes with them remember
to continue boosting your confidence
especially your party members and change
some hearts for more coverage on persona
5 royal stay tuned a game spot
you